change your environment so it's freezing
cold at my place right now the heat went
off it's 59 degrees 261 degrees
somewhere in there really cold and it's
book riding day and I need to be on top
of my game and being in a freezing cold
environment is not conducive to creating
some amazing content for you guys
and so my instinctive reaction is one I
got to get this fixed right I got to
call somebody get something to come over
and fix this and two I got to get out of
here right until it's fixed I can't be
here because it's not conducive to me
creating great things and as I was
thinking about that and in my reaction I
thought this is a really valuable lesson
for entrepreneurs because we all have
things in our environment that hold us
where we are the challenge is you may be
so used to always being cold that you're
just used to it you get comfortable
there and you don't recognize or realize
that there are warmer climates and other
opportunities for you to break free and
realize your true potential look at the
friends in your life look at the family
around you look at the habits that you
have look at the schedule that you keep
look at what you do with your time does
it support you creating something
amazing or not and if not what are you
doing about it
do you have the instinctive reaction
like I did for when it's cold to one try
to fix it in two get out until it is
fixed I can't stress enough to you guys
how important having a solid environment
it is for you because you can have the
greatest strategies in the world right
you could watch these videos and get the
greatest ideas and what to do and the
tactics and how to implement and you
might get momentary bursts of motivation
inspiration you see somebody doing
something great and now you want to go
off and do it too but the only way to
keep it consistent the only way to make
it a habit the only way to have
long-term success is to create that
environment around you that is conducive
to you being that big success to stop
being numb to the cold and to when you
realize that something is wrong do
something about it take action to try to
change it and until it is changed get
the heck out
so I'd love to know from you guys in the
comments what's the one thing that you
need to change in your environment
ASAP what's the one thing that is
holding you back that is making you live
a limited life that you need to change
and what are you gonna do about it
leave it in the comments below now let's
get to your questions first up then
picture I've been sharing your channel
with other people hopefully that will
help you hit your goal
I appreciate that bang I appreciate all
you guys for your sharing it really
means a lot to me last week I was
talking about how my goal was to hit a
million subscribers on my youtube
channel and honestly all the comments
all the engagement all the sharing all
the telling your friends really means a
lot to me I'm glad that I could be you
know a small part of your success and
thank you and thank you and please keep
doing it
next up Venkat can you talk about how
you manage time for all the things you
do I guess you are involved in so many
things about time management should be
one of your top priorities to succeed in
your different engagement thanks Venkat
this is something that used to suck out
and I've got way way way way way better
at there's a few things that I'm a big
believer in that helped me manage my
time the first is the concept of
eliminate automate delegate I think
we're doing too many things ourselves
things that are low value things that we
shouldn't be doing again you think of
yourself as an entrepreneur you want to
figure out what is the best thing that
you can do to have an impact on the
world what are you one of the greatest
people in the world at doing and try to
spend as much as your time doing that
compared to the other things and I think
not enough people do that and you spend
maybe 10 to 20 percent of your time
doing this stuff you're actually great
at and 80 to 90 percent of your time
doing stuff that you feel has to get
done but you're not one of the best in
the world at doing and you to break
through in order to really make your
mark that's what you need to switch off
price you have to start doing the stuff
that you're amazing at another something
you're mediocre and have no interest in
learning more about so eliminate start
by eliminating to a hard assessment of
where you're spending your time and what
you need to take out next is automate
taking out the things that are less
and thinking about how much can software
tools technology help me so I'm not
doing so many manual processes hide n3
is delicate there and that's figuring
out who can I give things to who are
passionate what they do that I'm not
passionate what needs to get done you
know as an example look at video editing
I love YouTube it's been a big part of
my success now it's where I spend a lot
of my time I love talking to you guys
and hearing your comments and making
videos for you I love being in front of
the camera I think that's the highest
value that I can bring and then being
engaged in the community editing is not
one thing that I'm great at and I don't
want to get better on it's not my list
of ambitions and desires to be a great
video editor and so that has to get done
and so I hired somebody to do it and
Christina and her husband Sam both
helped me in making these videos and
putting it up together and that's
allowed me to go from making one video a
week to now three videos a day
leveraging what I'm great at and
delegating a lot of the tasks off to
other people so I'd be looking at my
list constantly and looking at who can I
assign projects to doesn't have to be me
to do it that allows me to get a lot
more stuff done on top of that I'm a big
believer in chunking your time and so I
set my schedule I've talked about this a
couple times in the channel but I set my
schedule accordingly where Monday is my
now my new business day so I've I'm in
the process of a corner company that's
almost done I'll let you guys know when
that's finished and I spend Monday
working on that new business Tuesday
today is Tuesday is my writing day so
I'm walking to Whole Foods I'm going to
write the book finish up the editing and
get it off to my publisher in January to
us hopefully create an amazing book that
you guys all love Wednesday is my video
of creation day and so my videographer
Jason comes over and we've shoot our
videos for the week versus my
public-facing day
my meetings it's my radio show it's my
interviews you know anything that I'm
connecting with other people on phone
calls sales meetings anything is on a
Thursday and then Friday I have another
Jason Jay rise come over to my place and
we work on important projects to help
grow the business and so every day has
its own theme and Chungking my time
helps make sure that everything gets
done and lets me get a lot more done and
then finally I don't use a cell phone
and I think that's been a huge success
for me I think people get distracted way
too easily by their cell phone even just
having a phone I don't have a number
that you can call me on right the
problem with having a cell phone is that
people call you and people disrespect
your time and we're going to get that
time back
it's for you to respect your time first
and I think even if you don't pick up
the phone
the challenge is you look down and it
right somebody calls you you look down
at that phone number you think do I know
this person or not hmm and if you do
know the person but you wonder what they
want and even if you never answer the
phone the challenge is you've not wasted
time and more than them you know 60
seconds of wasting time thinking about
it it's that it took you off task and
when you're deep involved into projects
that you're passionate about adding a
ton of value either you're trying to be
creative at I need a little minor
distraction like that you know if I'm
writing my book
and somebody calls me and I have to look
back even if I don't answer that number
I look at it and have to get back now
into my book write it so I'm
just to get back to where it was because
of that 30 second interruption and so
guard your time for me it's not being on
the phone it's not having a cellphone
it's not having a number to call me at
it's not spending a ton of time on
social media except that specific times
that I've put in my calendar protect
your time right if you value yourself
you want to do big projects you want
other people to respect you and your
time you start by respecting your time
first next up ace Wilson turn your
five-year goals into one year goal best
advice I've heard in the wild yeah and
this is something that I try to
encourage people to do is the thing
bigger it's recognizing you can do
things faster I think a lot of people
have goals that are not massively
inspirational and hold you where you are
you think of somewhere that you want to
go in five years someplace that you want
to be in your career and your business
and your life and think to yourself why
does it have to take five years to get
there just ask the question you can
answering that question saying hey how
can I do this in one year how can I
crunch down that goal that timeline just
asking that question changes your
mindset changes how you think you'll
start to recognize opportunities that
you didn't see before and I'm a big
believer in it and you may not be able
to bring it down into one year that may
not be achievable or possible for you
but you'll get there a lot faster than
the five years that you thought it would
take and so it's something that I'm
doing on my channel right the goal is to
hit a million subscribers it forces me
to think bigger think differently
hopefully I'll get there with your
support and last up eat King oh the book
I want the book I feel your pain bro I
want the book too
there's an insane amount of work going
into it every single week pounding out
copy and I'm super excited for the
change that it's made to my business I'm
ready and doing the research and I'm
really confident excited and the change
is going to make to your businesses as
soon as it's ready to come out but we'll
let you know so thank you guys for the
support I'd love to know what you think
of this video if you have a question
about my book book writing process your
book leave in the comments below and
I'll make a video reply next time have a
great day guys I'll talk to you soon